no
griselda features on this
you know i i what i always look forward
to when i when i listen to any one of
y'all's projects is there's always that
posse cut
right right it's like spurs three you
know i mean there was not that on this
project
um was that done on purpose like what
like what was it like why no why no
conway or a gun on the album to be
honest with you
like i'm happy you asked me that because
people be thinking it's some weird [ __ ]
it's like [ __ ] just be doing what they
be doing
he westby over here living his life he
just had a baby he's hoping i'm sad
and to be honest with you like i'm gonna
be 100 honest like
i don't even be i don't look at them
[ __ ] as like
rappers like them [ __ ] is my big
cousin so right
part of me don't even want to bother
them [ __ ] you know what i'm saying i
don't think about it from the
fan point of view like we need this on
here because guess what you're going to
get
more benny and conway and that's just
another chapter and i might and i might
subconsciously sometimes we might even
hold those back because we know the
people waiting
you know what i mean we're going to
flood them shits on i had conway on 10
to talk three
two three times we're gonna say we're
gonna flood that [ __ ] next time or
we talking about doing a joint record
together but it's really that it's just
really
him in the midst of working on his album
i was working on burton the proof he
working on crazy [ __ ]
and we're just knocking records out well
you know how fans are they're gonna come
to their own conclusions
there's already been like rumors that
you guys are kind of becoming distant
and this the thing is like i think
what's happening
is what should be happening right like
you should be popping off bsf
shout out to conway he's got drum work
music exactly like you know what i'm
saying like
it just because you guys are evolving
and
and starting your own brands doesn't
mean that it's like any sort of love
lost or it ain't still griselda you know
what i mean i don't know what people be
thinking
it's because this [ __ ] be bored
bro they they they rather
push they're that narrative but they're
bored they're like
yo it'd be so crazy that people people
from
buffalo call me like yo man i read that
[ __ ] you and conway i'm like what
and guess what and me and kyle we had
never even speak about that [ __ ] we
never even
talked about that [ __ ] cause for what
you know what i'm saying
yeah should be crazy i think um
we're just so used as like as rap fans
we're so used to seeing our favorite rap
like clicks have some sort of
weird falling out but y'all are family
family
and and first and i'm gonna say this
griselda is griselda records we've never
been a group
people always say label we're not never
been a group we're not a group
right you know what i'm saying people
think we're a group there was a one
zelda album that was more like i look at
like a compilation
exactly that's really what it was you
what i'm saying so you know even though
y'all got the best group of the year bt
nomination
fire fire i mean y'all did get that so
at a point it's like
we maybe we are a group but you knew you
knew you knew
cam jim and santana was in a group they
the dips right you understood that they
were in a group it's the same thing with
us we're not a group
we're the gang though we the homies we
family but we're not a group so and i
know
people feel like when y'all together
y'all better we know all of that but you
know man
it's nothing more than just [ __ ] just
working on their own [ __ ] doing their
own thing